the co alarmists are now demanding that
we just forget about everything and move
on I wanted a harsher lockdown policy
and in retrospect I was wrong the the
damage to kids of keeping them out of
school longer was greater than the risk
but here's the bottom
line myself our great people the CDC I'd
like to thank the governor we were all
operating with imperfect information and
we were doing our best it's it's let's
learn from it let's learn from it let's
hold each other accountable but let's
bring a little bit of Grace and
forgiveness in that show the West we
should of course have the charity to
forgive people from our hearts we should
also have the Prudence to deprive those
people of the power that they abused and
we should prosecute them whenever
possible for the abuses and crimes that
they committed for which they have thus
far faced zero consequences